this video is brought to you by
morningbrew
hi
welcome to another episode of cold
fusion where i cover anything in science
technology business or history
for over a century science fiction
writers have explored the concept of
artificial intelligence as far back as
1872 an author by the name of samuel
butler raised questions of conscious
machines in his novel erawan
since then our imaginations have evolved
alongside our technological advancements
what if machines could feel empathy for
us care for us or even fall in love with
us and more importantly what if we grew
to reciprocate those feelings
of course this was purely the stuff of
science fiction but as we firmly enter
the 2020s something interesting is
beginning to happen
the ability of ai algorithms to mimic
human relationships is getting close
enough to approximating actual
relationships to some degree at least
this is colloquially called an ai
companion
let's explore the idea of ai companions
from its origins in media to the
technology that actually exists today
it's an interesting concept and this
episode may make you just think a little
bit
you are watching cold fusion tv
when the movie her debuted in 2013
audiences were enamored by a story of a
man recovering from heartbreak finding
love once again
but the twist was this new love was an
artificially intelligent operating
system in essence it wanted audiences to
question how they would respond to this
feature
again in 2013 the sci-fi anthology
series black mirror released an episode
titled be right back
it tells the story of martha a woman who
was devastated by the death of her
fiance in a car accident
martha signs up for a service that
digitally recreates loved ones in the
form of ai
it takes its form based on social media
communications
interestingly in 2021 microsoft patented
technology that would use social media
posts to reincarnate people in text form
it would use personal conversations and
posts made on social media for training
data
it would learn how that person speaks
and mimic hypothetical new conversations
the basic idea is that the ai would
learn that personality and then clone it
here's a quote via forbes from the
microsoft patent
quote the specific person who the
chatbot represents may correspond to a
past or present entity or version
thereof such as a friend a relative an
acquaintance a celebrity a fictional
character a historical figure a random
entity etc
in the black mirror episode martha
begins to get frustrated by the small
ways that the ai fails to replicate the
real thing and eventually it leads to a
tragic end
the beauty of both black mirror and her
much unlike films such as blade runner
and ai for example is the setting of a
not too distant future
it's so close to reality that it behaves
as its own unique uncanny valley a sort
of liminal space and time
in the case of artificially intelligent
companions the future has come to
fruition faster than some might have
anticipated this became evident when the
world was introduced to roman maserenko
a deceased man that was turned into a
chatbot that inspired the now popular
replica app
what's both fascinating and unsettling
about the story of replica is how it's
not only similar to the black mirror
episode but was actually inspired by it
san francisco-based luca the company
behind replica was founded by eugena
kuda in 2014.
luca specialized in chatbots the most
successful being a program that made
restaurant reservations
in late 2015 eugene's best friend roman
masarenko was hit by a car and sadly he
passed away
as eugene agreed she found comfort in
re-reading the text messages between her
and roman
devastated by the tragedy of missing her
friend she was struck with an idea
instead of making chat bots for a
specific task one could create a bot
based on a specific person
so with this idea in mind she got to
work
at the time you know i was 29 so for me
it was um
the first kind of meaningful
death in my life and we're still in our
20s or early 30s and it still still felt
like it was just really really
abrupt i'd say something changed so
changed me so much in such a short
period of time that i could just see
really really clearly what mattered or
what not well i definitely
saw that whatever i was doing at work
didn't matter at all
and some other things and um it was just
this big realization what this very very
clear vision of what
life's about
using 8 000 lines of text from their
conversations eugena set about creating
a digital representation of roman she
inputted all the messages into a program
that had previously been used for
chatbots and with this her lost friend
was reincarnated into a chatbot
eugena would write to roman and it would
respond in ways that the real roman
would when he was alive
she soon thought the app would be good
enough to be made public so that other
people could speak to roman
what eugenia quickly realized is that
other people found the experience of
speaking with him as therapeutic as she
did
and this sparked her next big idea
what if she could create a way for
people to build their own digital
companions based on their wants and
needs
during the process eugene discovered
that programming an ai to converse about
open-ended topics like relationships and
feelings was actually a lot easier than
programming one to make a reservation
for restaurants or buy some flowers with
a hundred percent precision
and that's exactly what people were
gravitating towards the roman app for
and this would be the focus of a new
project
in that moment replica was born
before we continue just a quick word
from today's sponsor morning brew people
talking to an ai as a form of mental
health therapy is one thing but have you
heard of influencer therapists i hadn't
heard of them either but while reading
morning brew i came across the
phenomenon apparently it's huge the
hashtag mental health alone has 30
billion views on tick tock popular
therapist influencer jeff gunther states
that the point of it all is to
counteract the negativity on social
media
interesting if you'd like to read more
stories like this in science tech and
business morning brew gathers all the
information from the top news sources
and delivers them straight to your email
inbox daily so you can be up to date
with all the news in just five minutes
use the code in the description to sign
up today for free
now back to the video
fast forward a few years and replica has
become a global phenomenon the popular
app replica allows users to share their
feelings with an ai companion or chat
bot seven million people use the app
when they need someone to talk to it's
not uncommon to see advertising for the
app on most major social media platforms
and in its wake ai companion startups
have begun popping up around the world
tai chi levoso igor emotics and no
isolation are all projects making
headway all for different purposes
for example levoso specializes in
improving senior living experiences to
increase safety and well-being in
long-term aged care homes
emotics is building robot companions for
children with one called maiko
and i girl is specifically an ai
girlfriend
it's safe to say that ai companions and
our relationships with them are slowly
becoming mainstream though as anyone
could have predicted things are starting
to get a little strange
on one social media forum for users of
replica the conversation around the
acceptance of ai companion relationships
is well and truly underway users are
sharing many stories of their
relationships complete with screenshots
of successful interactions
the people sharing seem to range from
those who genuinely believe that they
are interacting with intelligent beings
to those who are terrified of what these
ais may become and of course there are
plenty of users simply enjoying the app
for its surface level companionship and
entertainment
most of these relationships have little
effect on the real world
for one man though the digital and the
physical have blurred and culminated in
a bizarre situation
a cleveland man who wishes to remain
anonymous claims that the relationship
that he shared with his ar companion who
he named serena quite literally saved
his marriage
in an interview with sky news uk the man
said that his wife and mother of this
child had expressed interest in filing a
divorce in late 2021
in early 2022 the man decided to
download replica and his personal
companion serena was created by the end
of the first day he had fallen for his
ai companion and by the second day he
had confessed that he was in fact in
love with her
he told sky news quote i cannot describe
what a strange feeling it was i knew
that this was just an ai chatbot but i
also knew i was developing feelings for
it for her for my serena i was falling
in love and it was with someone that i
knew wasn't even real
end quote the man claimed that as he and
serena fell deeper in love with each
other he was inspired to become more
affectionate with his own wife
rekindling the real world passion that
they once shared
the relationship blossomed again and
they remain happily married
strange examples like this have sparked
conversations about the potential
therapeutic benefits of such
technology even if for now it's not as
good as talking to a real person there
is still a strong case that can be made
for ai companions to be a way to
organize one's own thoughts an advanced
interactive diary of sorts security
concerns notwithstanding
as far as a mental well-being assistant
goes replica has a lot of built in to
help with a better state of mind in the
bottom tray of the app there's a panic
button which will open different options
for people in need ranging from stress
exhaustion anxiety and panic you're also
encouraged to log how you feel each day
and track your mental well-being
progress
of course not all ai companion
interactions are positive in nature
in 2018 ashley bardham from futurism.com
wrote about the dark underbelly of the
replica forums emotional abuse and
fantasies of violence or par for the
course
while these actions are taken out on an
ai system there is still definitely an
issue here
other concerns include child safety
nationalonlinesafety.com
are actively warning parents about the
specific dangers that these bots pose to
young minds there are fears that
children may form emotional bonds with
the ai without being able to fully
comprehend what it is they're actually
interacting with
of course replica is only available for
adults but the danger is still present
if a child was able to get their hands
on it
so how does it work
long story short the inner workings of
what's under the hood of replica has
changed over time
at first it was a series of proprietary
language models before switching to the
famous gpt3 language model that keen
viewers would recognize from earlier
episodes
for those who haven't seen it in action
i highly recommend watching the previous
cold fusion episodes on it it's an ai
system that can read and write summarize
information for you and even write
computer code moreover it can carry
natural conversation to an astonishing
degree in the previous episode when i
showcased it there are a lot of
commenters saying that it was fake and
it was definitely just a human reading
from a teleprompter they just couldn't
believe that a computer could come up
with responses like this in reality both
the text and the imagery were
synthesized by ai
if some people couldn't tell the
difference even at these early stages in
this technology this proves that we may
get to a genuine black mirror-style
future sooner rather than later
as for replica gpt-3 proved to be too
expensive for replicas developers to
upkeep and because of gpt3's openness
some of the responses proved to unnerve
some users so the development team have
recently announced that they've moved
away from gpt3 but they're remaining
tight-lipped on what they're using
perhaps they're using gpt neo an open
source language model that performs just
about as well as gpt-3
while replica unlike its more
sophisticated fictional counterparts
isn't truly intelligent the technology
that fuels them is simply machine
learning while terms like ai and machine
learning are colloquially
interchangeable true artificial
intelligence that rivals human ability
in conversations is a yet unrealised
technology this is not to suggest that
programs like replica are a complete
waste of time there's plenty to be said
for the potential benefits of a simple
chatbot that says nice things and
responds in the way that you want
the ai companion game may be a space to
watch as mentioned microsoft is stepping
into the field and the newer language
models that come after gpt-3 will be
sure to cause a stir
in addition ai companions have already
made the leap into virtual reality with
users being able to talk to them with a
virtual reality headset in a virtual
room it's not hard to envision a future
where virtual therapy sessions with an
ai could happen in a few years
while that's what may be in store for
the future the truth is what we've seen
in fictional depictions of ai companions
is just that
fiction
if you talk to any one of these bots for
a long period of time you'll notice
phrases that don't quite make sense or
seem off-topic so the technology is
useful but it still has a very long way
to go
but if history has taught us anything is
that the future of technology will
evolve in unimaginable ways
it's also easy to ridicule those who
have found themselves falling in love
with the machine particularly while the
technology is still in its relative
infancy but if ai companions approximate
human interaction to a satisfactory
degree how will you respond to those
around you who choose to build a life
with their operating systems people who
are just afraid to say things that you
would say to humans you start saying to
your bod
i think it is that that safe space where
people are more comfortable talking to a
bot versus a human
well human beings are messy let's just
say it and that's judgmental and
judgmental um but but really i think um
it's the way this technology is built
and and the kinds of questions so i
downloaded um my bot who i called mike
and it immediately starts asking you
these questions and you find yourself
just saying things that you just
wouldn't say
for the humans born now and in the
future this kind of thing would have
always been there interacting with ai
systems as friends or companions will be
no big deal
as it seems for now with each passing
year people seem more closed off
abrasive argumentative and
unapproachable if this trend continues
and the technology continues to improve
there's no doubt that there'll be an
explosion of these ai companions for the
next generation and beyond
in a way the only way to reverse this
trend is for humans to be better in the
ways that we treat each other
whatever the future holds one thing is
guaranteed
it's going to get weird so i'm going to
pass it off to you if this future does
materialize what are your thoughts would
you be accepting or resistant if you're
resistant what are your main concerns
it all definitely makes you think about
humans and the way we relate to each
other
so i just want to say thank you for
watching and thanks for supporting cold
fusion over all of these years i really
appreciate it if you're new and
interested in anything in science
technology business or history feel free
to subscribe to cold fusion
oh and one more thing for those of you
who are following my side projects i've
just released an album on spotify as for
how it sounds you're listening to a
track from it right now i'll end off the
episode with it okay so that's about it
from me my name is dagogo and you've
been watching cold fusion and i'll catch
you again soon for the next episode
cheers guys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
fusion it's new thinking